So Indiana, what was the TC for like snap Uber and like Google. Yeah.
So it depends on how you calculate it,
but basically around 300 K for snap and Uber,
and then for Google about like 240K.
Was crazy before we continued as video. I just want to say,
thank you so much for blinkers, for sponsoring this video. Nowadays,
people are so busy. We have full-time jobs, hobbies, friends, or like me,
you have a YouTube channel to run.
So you can't just find the time to sit down and learn.
There is tons of knowledge you can learn from reading books,
but with the busy schedule, that's hard.
If you wish you can get the main insights from the books and apply right away to
your life, then I really recommend the app called Blinkist.
Blinkist is the only app that takes the best insights.
Didn't need to know information from thousands of nonfiction books and convinces
them down into just 15 minutes. So you can read it or listen to it.
A lot of nonfiction books tend to repeat itself or give a lot of example.
So that's why I like blink because it gets straight to the point and it tells
you in 15 minutes, I use blinkers right before bed for 15 minutes,
allowing me to absorb all that knowledge before sleeping.
I've read these books and I highly recommend you check out the seven habits of
highly effective people, because everyone talks about it. And also a homo Deus,
which is cool because it talks about a prediction of humanity with technology.
Now, the first a hundred people to go on blinkus.com/joma.
We'll get a whole week for free, so you can try it out.
And also you get 25% off.
If you decide to go for full membership. Now these spots are going to go fast,
but for people who get in there, I highly recommend reading those two books.
I mentioned, which is seven habits of highly effective people and homo Deus.
Now remember the first seven days are completely free,
so you could cancel at any time. No problem.
All right. Thanks for coming. Cyrus, do you want to say your name first?
Sure. Uh, wait, look at you. Alright.
[Inaudible] okay.
All right. Well thank you for coming Cyrus. And, um, yeah,
so let's just have like a casual conversation cause you know,
I'm not try-hard anymore, so we can just say yes, your name,
like what do you do? And then just so that he could get some context. Sure.
Uh I'm Cyrus. She, I just recently joined Uber. Um.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, so I met, uh, I met gentleman at Facebook. Uh,
we are in the same team in, in July, 2017.
Um, and then I was there for about a year and a half, um,
and then went through interview prep cycle. Um, so yeah.
Nice. Nice. So wait, so what college did you go to?
Uh, I went to a small liberal arts college in Kentucky. Uh,
I had about 1400 students called center college.
Inch and 1400 students, 4,000 students total. Wait the total total. Yeah,
like five, four years. Four years. Yeah, that's crazy. Yeah.
And w what does liberal arts college? I actually don't know.
Uh, so basically they try to emphasize like a general education. Um,
so trying to like produce well-rounded students. Uh, so when I was there,
I wrote a lot of like papers. I was really a philosophy major. Um,
so I switched to computer science junior year. Um.
I see, I see. Okay.
So the reason why I brought you here is because you have a very famous post on
CSV or questions right. On Reddit. So, yeah.
So I'm going to put that in the description,
but can you kind of tell me like what that post is about?
Yeah, yeah. So basically I spent a lot of time reading the subreddit, um,
before I joined Facebook. Um, and I saw a lot of posts talking about, um,
people joining, you know, like Facebook, Google, um, big tech companies.
And a lot of them had, um, you know,
like pretty impressive backgrounds from like Stanford, you know, U Waterloo,
Stanford of Canada. Um, but you know, I came from a small liberal arts college.
I didn't really know anybody who had gone to any of those companies. Um,
and so when I did eventually make it out there,
I thought I could give back and talk about how I, yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So you did have a CS degree, but it's from like a college, right.
Pretty much. But then, and then when you came out,
you got what you got a job at, like, yeah.
Yeah. So I graduated, uh, in the beginning of 2015 and I joined, uh,
like a big financial company, um, still in the South. Um, and then, uh,
then I joined a startup and then, um,
throughout this time I had been getting like interview calls, um,
for like Amazon, Microsoft, Google, but, um,
I just didn't really focus on studying and didn't really do well. Uh,
and then finally I got another call from Facebook and I decided that, you know,
this was the moment you're going to go try hormone, try hard mode.
I went all in and I studied like 120 hours in like a month while working full
time. Um, it's really grinded and just wrote a post about that experience.
That's perfect because, um, I just quit my job, you know, it,
but my audience doesn't know, I just quit my job as a data scientist,
and now I want to go back into Sweden, you know, so, uh,
I've already prepared and I've interviewed a lot,
but I want to hear like your take, like, how did you start? Like, okay.
You know, you have your full-time job still,
do you quit or no use to just study on the side? Would it.
Yeah, I think ideally you don't quit because, you know, it's really risky. Um,
but it, it does depend.
I have a friend who successfully quit her job and studied full time. Uh,
and she was actually, you know, Austin, North Carolina, um, and made it out to,
uh, Silicon Silicon Valley. But, um,
so I think the benefit of quitting is that it's kind of like,
you get like a forcing function, you get that desperation. Um,
but obviously it's a big gamble if it doesn't work out, you're kind of screwed.
Um, but yeah, ideally you keep your, and you study on the side. Um.
So yeah. Okay. So you study on the side yeah. Study on the side both times.
So you just went back home and then start studying.
Uh, yeah. So not, yeah, pretty much every day, I guess. But basically the,
I came up with a, like a study plan and a schedule sort of a timeline. Um,
and then one thing, uh, so I just recently another posts,
but one thing I talk about is that I think it really helps to have like a
quantifiable like goals, um,
just because it's so easy to become frustrated in the beginning. Um,
and it's hard to tell,
like if you're making progress and so my goals were to study, you know,
like a hundred hours and to do like a hundred coding problems.
Oh. A hundred coding problems. Okay.
And what did you use for these coding problems?
Yeah, so I mainly use li code. Um, so li codes really trendy right now,
but I think it gives a premium for it. Yeah, I did. I did.
I think it was worth it, uh, just the return on investment. Um, but yeah,
so I did a lot of li code I think was the most efficient, uh, Webster.
So before Facebook, you did Lee code?
Uh, I did, yeah, I did some, I did some for Facebook. I did,
I think I did about, uh, like 76%. And then this time around,
I did like 130 heart mediums or easy, um, mostly mediums.
I think mediums is the best bang for your buck. Easy is, um,
you can cycle there a lot and really fast,
but you don't really like struggle that much.
So you don't really get that experience. And then hearts are like,
you struggle too much, so you don't cover it.
Hmm. Okay. But your job at Facebook was as a data engineer. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
What do you do now?
So now I'm a software engineer, so actually I guess, similar to you,
I wanted to transfer back to being a software engineer. Um, but yeah,
I didn't really find that transition too hard. I think, uh,
interviewing the mostly want to see if like, if,
if you can code and if you can show that through the Kony interview,
they don't really.
Okay. So, so did an engineer, they still asked you like to code stuff? Yeah.
Like algorithms and stuff. Okay.
So you did about 70 something questions and was that like an overkill for
Facebook or was it.
Uh, yeah,
so for Facebook it was a little bit overkill because that was a data engineering
position. Um, but this time around for like Uber and Google, um,
it was about the right amount, I think.
So your goal was a hundred hours, like total, total until you started.
The interview. Yeah. So I ended up doing about 120, but I think, uh,
we for before Facebook, no, sorry. Before Facebook, it was, uh, I remember,
yeah, sorry.
Video here.
Before Facebook. It was,
I guess like 102 or 120 or something like that. Um,
but yeah, I, yeah, I, I tracked my time just because I feel like, um,
if you only track problems,
then you're like incentivize to like only do easy problems in a way like
subconsciously. And if you only attract time, it's kind of like,
you you're incentivized to be inefficient. I spend a lot of time for problem.
Like, it doesn't really matter.
So that's why I got kind of like a kind of metric. Yeah, exactly.